here either than hiya today we have to
first return life to normal in all
provinces and respect the rule of law
under which everyone lives in safety and
stability I'd like to assure you that
the security procedures we undertook
which included blocking roaming data
temporarily was a difficult decision
however it is like bitter medicine it
was mandatory because we cannot afford
to lose your security or take risks or
to leave your safety and the country in
the wind preserving security is regarded
as the highest in this country's
interest and nationally is a priority of
so far government efforts to stop the
protests have failed
Imran Khan reports from Baghdad they
defied the curfew imposed by Iraq
security forces and for not following
soldiers orders bullets were fired
anti-government demonstrations in the
capital Baghdad for the past three days
have also spread to other cities such as
Basra nazriya and Amara as the violence
escalated security forces blocked major
roads and the internet is also blocked
in most parts to sever social media
protesters are demanding a change of
government as well as more jobs less
corruption and an end to religious
discrimination in spite the curfew we
are going out to call for our rights we
want to change the regime they've
arrested our people they've done things
to our people that they did not even do
- - they beat them up and humiliated
them while firing live gunfire what did
we do
are we suicide bombers we are here to
call for our rights the number of dead
has risen steadily and over a thousand
have been injured since the defeat of
ISIL protesters say nothing has changed
them despite the promises of politicians
even with the curfew I swear to god we
will not retreat we're demanding our
simplest rights the simplest rights that
we asked for you know what we sacrifice
ourselves for our country to be
sacrifice for Iraq our people come out
not for yourselves but for your children
Iraqis are also unhappy with the abrupt
dismissal of Abdulwahab al-saadi who led
to counterterrorism forces in the fight
against ISIL analysts say the
government's reaction to the protests is
a dangerous escalation Eric's fragile
security relies on managing deep a
sectarian fault lines as well as a
threat from the remnants of ISIL the
people are being robbed the people are
begging on the street there is no work
you come to protest and they fire at you
Iran has closed two border crossings
delaying plans by millions of Iranian
pilgrims to visit Iraq for a religious
ritual Iraq's US allies and the United
Nations are appealing to Iraq's
government to exercise restraint prime
minister Adel of the Mahdi and his
year-old government is facing its
biggest challenge yet but it's unclear
how he can stop the outpour of anger
against his rule with no apparent
leaders of the protesters to negotiate
with
Imran Khan al Jazeera Baghdad